sup guys Edgar here hey I'm down here
that's my butthole god damnit I mean hey
guys Edgar here just want to let you
know that I'm taking over this channel
now because Pierce is uh he's uh anyway
from now on I will be making all the
videos on this channel and to give you a
little sample of all the good stuff
that's about to come here's me playing a
horror game
[ __ ] that [ __ ] here's me playing call of
duty
oh man I love Call of Duty wait this is
not Call of Duty
here's me doing the dog food challenge
all of them all the Bob dog oh it's so
disgusting ah I can't believe I did that
four views so anyway uh suggest me what
you want to see on this channel now that
I've taken over and okay what are you
doing I was just checking your equipment
to make sure you wouldn't get hurt again
come on man it's April Fool's god dammit
I'm gonna say it Edgar come on please
I'm gonna do it please don't do it I'll
do anything don't do it dosha the
memories
they've all come back those horrible
images